hello and welcome to the 19th PHP
tutorial in last tutorial we left off
with these idea of HTML entities and how
you can protect yourself against some
malicious attacks so with that the next
thing that I just want to bring up
before we continue on with the fun and
beauty of PHP and making websites is one
more security risk so initially you know
what we've done is we've already
converted HTML entities but that won't
always protect you for awhile everyone
thought well ok if you use HTML entities
like that's all you got to do to protect
yourself but really what you have to you
have to be really stringent you know the
only way you can really protect yourself
against most attacks I mean there's
probably no way to ever be a perfectly
secure website but the best way that you
can do this is at least when you have
like forms like this where people can
input data is you first you know kind of
do everything it takes to kind of run
through that data before you go to
display that data in any way so and as
you run through it you know the first
thing you'll want to do definitely HTML
entities there is one more thing that
you want to do and so if you ever if you
have a header file like we do you'll
want to pop over to your header file and
come down here and you'll want to
specify some header information and so
what we're going to say is we're going
to just stay content you know tight and
that is going to be text HTML and then
you want to specify car set as
utf8 right to give you an example it's
been how long ago it was me a couple
years or a year or something but without
you TFA if you had you tf7 you could
still pass through JavaScript right even
though it was you know not reading HTML
you could still put through JavaScript
so it's just best to make sure you do
everything you can to specify you know
specific things within any form where
you've got people submitting anything
right it's just a good idea
same thing like with your SQL database
like there's if you don't set that up
right someone can just enter a drop
command into your database and just drop
your database so you just you have to
understand how these things work and
make sure that you've kind of got at
least some protection against malicious
activity and if you don't know how to
specify like specific header information
it's a it's more of a PHP thing so you'd
want to do this
and we're going to choose utf-8 and then
we'll just throw in welcome to this but
we could also just since we're at this
point why don't we just go ahead and
echo out
so now we're back to a decent website so
the next thing that we want to do is
return back to the string manipulation
ideas that we were going to start
talking about so with that let's hop
into it so let's say you know this is
example text submit okay
so right now they're the exact same
thing well what can we do to manipulate
text
well let's pop over here and we're done
with our header file for now so I'll
just close that out and within here the
change text this is where we're going to
start changing things so the easiest
thing we can do is upper case and lower
case to do this you've got STR to lower
or STR to upper so we can test echo STR
to upper the most fun one and in case
that like so we'll save that upload that
and pop over here and what we'll do is
sample text submit and you see this is
the rage original text change text is
example text okay so you can see that
we've changed that so the next thing
that we'd want to do is pop back over
here and we can do string to lower okay
so we'll save that put that up on the
server and now we can do tab and this is
my tutorial and we'll capitalize
tutorial and we'll submit that and you
can see it just completely lowercased
everything this makes string parsing and
dealing like processing strings a lot
easier when you convert it to the same
case the other thing you can do is look
for things within text so to do that
let's specify a variable and just to
remind you
I guess we'll just do it right in here I
guess so we'll say what cost variable
look for and we want to look for cat and
when you use this command you want to
encase what you want to look for with
these forward slashes so we want to look
for cat and the way that we do that is
let's make an if statement so it'll be
if and then parameters curly braces and
the command for looking for this is
going to be P reg underscore match and
in this we are looking for you first
have what you're looking for so in this
case we're looking for look for and then
the next one is where are we going to
look for this and in this case we're
going to look for this within text so we
close that off and then if we do find it
you want to echo found . look for .
space and text close it and semicolon so
we'll save that and send that in
hopefully we did this wrapping up we
didn't put a semicolon there and I think
we're good otherwise so save that send
it forward and again submit nothing it
just wore cased it hello this is a test
or let's do cats submit
and it says found cat in text because it
can't found cat within the word cats so
what if you just wanted to find cat so
what if we do like cat space and
actually let's do cat space that because
like what if what if we just want to
look for it let's do it this way first
and send that back game and if we do
hello this is a tutorial for cats to me
and it didn't say it found anything but
what if we do hello this is a tutorial
for a bobcat in fact it won't even find
that this is a bobcat for it submit so
now it'll find anything that ends in cat
but then of course if you just wanted to
find solely cat you wouldn't you would
do that so that's how you do P reg match
and then also how to do a couple other
commands to your strings so as always
thank you for watching and stay tuned to
the next video